[Applause]  hi everybody nice to see you yeah you  look good  yeah yeah you're fine you're good you  look good Coney well we're we're in  suits now yeah here's the thing about  Adam Adam never dresses up I have seen  you at like formal occasions and you are  wearing basketball shorts a tank top  it's I don't want to know it's like I  always want the rest of the clothes are  itchy yeah but this is pretty good for  you to eat oh yeah this is good you have  pants on when I was a kid I never told  anybody this I was molested by a freshly  pressed pair of slacks and the worst  part was a pair of Tom McCann shoes we  were in the room watching  [Laughter]  you